president Trump lighting up the world
stages impeachment enters a new phase
the House Intelligence Committee
expected to vote soon on Chairman Adam
shifts newly released report the GOP
releasing their own free bottle report
it says there's no evidence of an
impeachable offense and warns that the
Democrats are sending a dangerous
precedent Trump signing off on all of
this while he attends the NATO summit in
London I think it's very unpatriotic of
the Democrats to put on a performance
where they do that I do I think it I
think it's a bad thing for our country
impeachment wasn't supposed to be used
that way I think it's a disgrace I
didn't the Democrats should be ashamed
of themselves
the Republicans have never been stronger
never been more unified the Democrats
have gone crazy
the president's saving more harsh words
for Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Chairman
Adam chef Jeff is a deranged human being
and he grew up with a complex a lots of
reasons that are obvious I think he's a
very sick man
and he lies Jeff made up my conversation
with the president of Ukraine Nancy
Pelosi knew he was lying and she went on
her show Stephanopoulos and she said he
told the truth so she was lying - these
people are deranged Greg the president
over there in the UK trying to do some
business but he's got to deal with
politics back home well the question is
is is this unpatriotic so I was thinking
about that for quite a while Danny
because I like to think all right is it
unpatriotic on patriotic to undo an
election in a process that started the
day after the election yeah I'd say
that's unpatriotic trying to cancel the
votes of half the country to soothe your
emotional damage because daddy hurts you
that's unpatriotic it says a lot about
your emotional state proceeding with
this circus knowing that there was a
split in the country that half the
countries against it
yeah it's unpatriotic as you know could
it create widespread discontent and
perhaps economic collapse yeah I would
say that's unpatriotic so you're
pursuing all of this rather than
participate in an election that you
start you started this process three
years ago
it's all because you feel bad inside
you're putting your feelings before the
country that's unpatriotic Adam ships
though Juan says in his report that the
president broke the rule a he's talking
about bribery and then in particular
they spent a lot of time in the report
talking about the president obstructing
the process indeed and it's interesting
you know picking up on what Greg was
talking about from the Democrats
perspective they're more interested in
2020 than they are in 2016 because what
they say is that this president was
soliciting foreign nations interfering
in the upcoming election so it to me
it's like you have two reports out today
Dana one from the Republicans one from
the Democrats and it's like alternate
realities it's like listening to me and
Greg on what's real and you have the GOP
the GOP saying hey there's not enough
evidence here for impeachment where is
the hard evidence where the the direct
testimony from anybody about a quid pro
quo bribery whatever and then you have
the Democrats come out and they say this
unbelievable unprecedented obstruction
of justice and obstruction of an
impeachment process telling people not
to come testify before an equal branch
of government to Congress keeping
documents away from Congress and we have
out a call log and that was the one
thing that really struck me the the
Republicans are really all about the
political argument the Democrats offers
some factual basis saying here are call
logs that demonstrate how Devin Nunez
who's the lead Republican on house and
Intel was involved with Rudy Giuliani
the president's lawyer with the
president with lead Parnassus guy who's
been indicted for a financial campaign
they had the call logs but they don't
have what they said yeah but it sure is
it sure looks bad I think it's
interesting that Adam Schiff the
chairman was looking at phone calls made
by the ranking member who he's supposed
to be working with on this committee to
come to some kind of agreement about how
to move forward so it's obvious for us
no love yeah yeah they certainly won't
be getting along in the future but it is
interesting how Adam Schiff claims that
he has all of this information to move
forward but the process it's urgent that
they get it to the Judiciary Committee
and they will continue to investigate
even after it's handed over while also
admitting that they don't have all of
you the information that they haven't
interviewed key people that were named
in this testimony who haven't spoken to
him and it's very clear that shift
doesn't have the confidence to go
through the court system to try and find
out if he has the authority to haul
people like secretary Pompeo and I about
going to court Jessie I'm sure you have
a lot of thoughts on this well I mean
we're talking about impeaching the
president wands talking about call logs
think about that we were promised high
crimes and misdemeanors and Juan is
talking about a call log come on Juan
you went home to Thanksgiving no one's
talking about Ukraine my liberal mother
is not talking about Ukraine the whole
thing backfired if you look at every
single swing state impeachments now
underwater this unified republican is
more than a unified Democrats Democrats
are broke the DNC has no money
Republicans are raising money like I'm
not going to say it they're raising a
lot of money and now they're trying to
play all these tricks like they did with
Kavanagh all of a sudden ambassador
Sandlin gets it with not one not two but
three sexual harassment allegations in
the middle of all this and you have
Trump over there with Melania looking
very striking meeting with world leaders
fresh off killing Baghdady and unifying
NATO against the Russians and then you
have Adam Schiff passing this scam to
little Jerry Nadler who's supposed to
carry it across the finish line I just
don't see how this thing is going to
stick and even swing state Democrats
know it because they're whispering about
ways to get out of having to vote for
this now but now Greg the Democrats are
kind of in this box right if they don't
go forward their base is gonna be
furious but if they do go forward they
could pay the price at the ballot box in
the swing states they I think we
predicted this didn't wait and saw this
coming I for one hope they continue with
this because you know it's something to
talk about on the five during the slow
days but I do feel that I refuse to be
led by the nose by ship with these fake
little like inquiries reports and
whatnot it's all it's to your point it's
all much ado about nothing something I
think I can
but one thing I want to say about
watching Trump today at these meetings
his mantra is they owe us money right so
everything he does is on behalf he's
like those these are agent he's
America's agent in a meeting and he's
such a jerk but he's our jerk did you
see how he dealt with the Canadian he
treated him as though he was the manager
of a golf course owned by Trump can you
tell us what did we worked out here what
is it you owe us and he made and what's
his name again
Trudeau let me go through this I think
we got to 70% and he's like basically
saying yes sir yes it was a gate it was
like Celebrity Apprentice yeah I mean it
was interesting to see that everything
he does is on behalf of America he's
that uncomfortable person who goes up to
somebody and says you owe us money not
the other side of this was to watch him
deal with the French from right there
where you saw you know it was to me it
was like he was lecturing Trump I
thought Trump in that exchange look like
you think that this is about terrorism
no I think it's about not fear because
you didn't pay me the money actually you
guys are paying but we're getting other
people and we've done so much better and
NATO was going to fold and now and he's
like no for is it for terrorists or is
it for Russians and the president could
not agree well but I but I do think that
perhaps McCrone had a little I don't
know if he planned it or not but the
president has been quite critical of
NATO then McCrone was critical of NATO
called it brain dead and the president
said how dare you say that NATO is
amazing right NATO's amazing so maybe
everybody wins